there's a new statue in Boston of Martin
Luther King
I think I guess
the statue is
getting a lot of play online
because it some have said there are two
theories on what it looks like some have
said that it it looks like it's just I
guess it's just arms interwoven together
some have said that from certain angles
it looks like a man engaged in another
kind of embrace which is not as as
wholesome as the Embrace of two arms
that's one some have said it looks like
a man holding up
part of one's body that is not an arm
and some have said that it looks like a
guy
hoisting up
excrement that I'm trying to clean up
all the jokes that I've seen online
about this very very ugly statue but
apparently according to the artist it is
a statue
commemorating and embrace between Martin
Luther King and his wife Coretta king
and the sculptor Hank Willis Thomas
says that he saw this 1964 photo of MLK
wrapping Coretta up for a hug after
hearing that he'd won the Nobel Peace
Prize and so this modern artist decided
to depict this in a sculpture only with
the arms
and it's really really ugly
why is it ugly most people don't seem to
identify why the sculpture is ugly the
sculpture is ugly because it is
grotesque and the sculpture is grotesque
in precisely the way that modernity is
grotesque
which is that it it forgets that people
are supposed to have heads and chests
the modern art is depicting people as
just weird limbs disconnected from the
rest of the body disconnected from the
most important parts of the body
the the mind that makes us rational and
the chest which gives us spiritedness
which which represents courage which
represents our beating heart
the lifeblood moving through US
modernity doesn't view men through the
lens of heads and chests C.S Lewis wrote
a very very famous work on men without
chests men who lose their spiritedness
men who lose their Manliness
and the whole culture seems to have lost
its head has completely lost its reason
that's why we let men go into the girls
room and why we listen to what stupid Dr
fauci has to say Okay so
people know intuitively
that Modern Art is ugly and grotesque
and we don't like it and yet we keep
seeing so much more of it why is that
one it's because of the absolute
perversion of the people who happen to
be in power but two it's because we
often fail to give perfectly rational
explanations of why Modern Art is so
ugly
well we all know it's ugly you look at a
at a 14th century Cathedral and you look
at the Embrace this weird melange of
arms kind of scooping together
we know that one is more beautiful than
yet look at the pieta look at the
Embrace tell me which one's more
beautiful
look at
beautiful Gothic buildings look at ugly
modern skyscraper type buildings we know
that the former are more beautiful than
the latter
but we don't trust our own prejudices we
don't trust our own gut our gut is is
Right more often than our scientists are
that is a that is a Roger Kipling wrote
a great great piece on this great poem
The the gods of the copy book headings
and people why is people throughout all
of human history have understood that
time-tested wisdom the wisdom of the
tradition
is 99 times out of 100 at least going to
be better than whatever newfangled idea
happens to pop into your head this is
why I'm
often defending traditional conservatism
as opposed to different brands of
conservatism like neo-conservatism or
libertarianism which is often lumped in
with conservatism I often go back to
traditional conservative views with an
emphasis on tradition
not because I think that a practice that
has been done for a long time is the
be-all and end-all and that any old
practice ought to be continued into
perpetuity but just because I trust the
wisdom of the countless generations of
men who came before us more than I trust
the prideful ideas of some over
credentialed undereducated dummy in a
lab coat head on over become a member
right now use code Knowles kwles
dailywire.com Knowles use code nulls at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign
[Music]